you are probably familiar with the basic
states of matter
solid liquid and gas that fills everyday
life on earth but turns out they aren't
the whole of the universe
scientists have discovered dozens of
more exotic states of matter in the past
often bearing mystical names such as
superfluids
bose einstein condensates
and neutron degenerate matter
and now a new exotic phase of matter was
created with the help of a quantum
computer with just as mystical name the
time crystal
here's what's intriguing about the time
crystal
it is governed by completely different
physical laws compared to other known
phases of matter
water gas and ice
are always in thermal equilibrium which
means that their atoms have settled into
the state with the lowest energy and
their properties don't change with time
the time crystal on the other hand is
the first out of equilibrium phase
it has order and perfect stability
despite being in a constantly evolving
state
the special time crystals were first
theorized in 2012 by physicist and
mathematician frank wilczyk
who suggested crystal's structural
repetition could exist in the fourth
dimension as well as it did in the third
it wasn't until 2016 that the first
blueprint for how to make these a
possibility really surfaced
that year a group of physicists helped
to clarify wilksec's idea taking it from
something entirely fictional to a real
world possibility
the team defined the kind of
circumstances under which a time crystal
could occur
a quantum system without thermal
equilibrium and one which cannot be
described by any temperature since
temperatures naturally suggest
equilibrium
fast forward to today using google's
quantum computer a few researchers were
finally able to create a time crystal
that they think firmly establishes time
crystals in the world of physics
but how exactly were they able to create
it what defines any crystal such as a
diamond or an emerald is that the
crystals atoms are arranged in repeating
patterns in space
we know from physics that there are
three dimensions of space
length
width and height
as well as a fourth dimension time
so physicists wondered if a crystal's
atoms could be arranged in repeating
patterns in the fourth dimension time
in practice that works something like
this
you create a crystal whose atoms start
in one state if you blast that crystal
with a laser those atoms might flip into
another state and then flip back and
then flip again and so forth all without
actually absorbing any energy from the
laser
if you step back what you've just
created is a state of matter that's
perpetually in motion indefinitely
without taking in any energy
a time crystal is an object whose parts
move in a regular repeating cycle
sustaining this constant change without
burning any energy
with the ability to forever cycle
between two states without ever losing
energy time crystals dodge
one of the most important laws of
physics the second law of thermodynamics
according to the second law of
thermodynamics the disorder of an
isolated system must always increase
to explain how deeply unusual this
behavior is let's try to picture a
sealed box filled with coins before
being shaken a million times
as the coins ricochet from and bounce
around each other they become more and
more chaotic
exploring all of the sorts of
configurations that they can explore
until the shaking stops and the box is
open to reveal the coins in a random
configuration with roughly half of the
coins facing up and half facing down
we can expect to see this random half up
half down end point regardless of the
way we first arranged the coins in the
box
inside the box of google's quantum
computer sycamore we can view the
quantum processor's qubits much like we
would our coins
in the same way that the coins can be
either heads or tails qubits can be
either a one or a zero the two possible
positions in the two-state system
or a weird mix of the probabilities of
both states called a superposition
google's qubits consist of
superconducting aluminum strips
each has two possible energy states
which can be programmed to represent
spins pointing up or down
perhaps the main advantage of the
google's quantum machine over its
competitors is its ability to tune the
strengths of interactions between its
qubits
this tunability is key to why the system
could become a time crystal the
programmers could randomize the qubit's
interaction strengths and this
randomness created destructive
interference between them that allowed
the row of spins to achieve many body
localization the researchers gave the
spin's arbitrary initial configurations
such as
up down down
up
and so on
then they pump the system with microwave
lasers flipping spins up and down and
vice versa
by running tens of thousands of demos
for each initial configuration and
measuring the states of the qubits after
different amounts of time the
researchers could observe that the
system of spins was flipping back and
forth between too many body localized
states
the researchers found that the spins
never absorbed or dissipated net energy
from the microwave laser leaving the
disorder of the system unchanged
these unusual time crystals lasted for
roughly 100 seconds
they remained stable resisting any
dissolution into randomness despite
existing in a constant state of flux
the existence of this weird new matter
phase and the entirely new realm of
physical behaviors it reveals is
incredibly exciting especially as time
crystals were only first predicted to
exist just nine years ago
google's experiment is likely to remain
the best way to study time crystals for
the foreseeable future
the newly discovered crystals might help
make quantum computers become more
robust
engineers have struggled for years to
create something that could serve as
memory in quantum computers
some equivalent to the silicon that
underpins traditional computers
time crystals physicists think could
serve that purpose
if you found this video useful i would
appreciate it if you smash the like
button
also make sure to subscribe to the
coding tech channel and click on the
notification bell enjoy the rest of your
day